اعلن رئيس المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات
التركيه احمد ينار اجراء جوله ثانيه من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد اظهار النتائج
الاوليه للانتخابات عدم حصول اي مرشح على
النسبه الكافيه للفوز في هذه الحلقه
الخاصه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر ولنا في
نقاش خبرها ثلاثه مسارات ما هي ابرز
الخلاصات التي يمكن استنتاجها من النتائج
الاوليه للانتخابات التركيه الى اين يتجه
المشهد السياسي التركي على ضوء هذه
النتائج وما هي الارتدادات على علاقات
انقره بمحيطها الاقليمي والدولي
[موسيقى]
على النتائج حسب التحالفات نرى ان تحالف
الجمهور قد فاز في انتخابات البرلمان وحصل
على اغلبيه المقاعد
321 فقط يعني اما الانتخابات الرئاسيه
ايضا الرئيس اردوغان تقدم منافسه خمسه في
المئه من الاصفاد فلذلك نرى هناك نجاح فوز
بارز ان حزبنا هو ايضا الاحزاب الاخرى وما
كسبناه في هذه الانتخابات
هنالك انخفاض
في نتائج حزب العداله والتنميه وهنالك
تصاعد
تدريجي في الاحزاب المعارضه تحالف
الشاء قد نجح بشكل كبير قد لا تعكس هذه
لكن على المدى الطويل سنرى هنالك الكثير
من النجاحات التي ستتحقق كان سقف الطاوله
السداسيه مرتفع جدا قبيل الانتخابات كان
الحديث عن حسم في الرئاسه وعن تقدم ايضا
في البرلمان لصالح المعارضه وهذا كله لم
يتحقق نعم ما كان
الطموح والحماسه عاليه وكان الاشخاص ضمن
التحالف كانوا يركزون على الانتخابات
الرئاسيه ربما كان هذا الامر خاطئا اننا
ركزنا كثيرا على الانتخابات الرئاسيه ولم
نركز بنفس الشيء على الانتخابات
البرلمانيه
ماذا كان هدف
تحالف الامه هناك هدف واحد وهو تغيير
النظام رئاسي الى نظام برلماني عندما حصل
تحالف الجمهور اغلبيه البرلمان هذا الهدف
قد زال لم يبقى لتحالف الامه هدفا وليس له
قدره في تغيير لا النظام ولا اي شيء
بالنسبه في
مجال التشريع اعتقد ان الحمل
الانتخابيه الان
سيتم نسيانها في المرحله الاولى وستبدا
سيبدا المعسكراني ربما بحمله جديده من
الصور والفيديوهات الجديده نحن هنا
موجودون لاننا نمثل 50% اذا ما نظرت الى
اردوغان هو حقق 50% لكن هنالك 50% لا
يختلفون ما التا ثيرات المحتبله على
مستقبل التحالفات بعد النتائج التي تكشفت
في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات انا
اتوقع ان يكون هناك
تغيرات في داخل التحالف انما التحالفان
كلاهما
سيسعيان
للقصور على الاصوات التي ذهبت الى
هناك خمسه بالمئه من الاصوات موجوده فهذه
الاصوات هي التي
ستشكل مصير
الانتخابات في الجوله الثانيه
بالتاكيد هناك تاثيرات
سنراها فيما بعد خاصه بعد الجوله الثانيه
التي
سيفوز فيه الرئيس اردوغان في السياسه
الداخليه لان في الداخل هناك قضايا يجب ان
تواجهها الحكومه على راسها الغلاء وعلى
راسها المنطقه المنكوبه وكذلك مكافحه
الارهاب
وكذلك هناك قضايا ايضا خارجيه
تتاثر من نتائج هذه الانتخابات لان
التركيه اذا عند فوز السيد اردوغان
اردوغان سياسته الخارجيه تبنى على المحور
التركي لا تبنى لا على المحور الغربي ولا
على المحور الامريكي ولا الروسي سياسه
متوازنه